[Music]
dave is with us in orlando florida hi
dave how are you
uh well i think better than i deserve
good good how can i help
well dave are you in a good mood today
i'm working on it merry christmas what's
up
merry christmas so i'm about to ruin it
for you i'm going to get on one of your
favorite topics my father-in-law died
about seven years ago and i've been
doing the been doing the debt snowball
and everything i'm getting there getting
close to uh that uh the debt-free zone
and lo and behold we got a christmas
card in the mail this past week of a
lawsuit from a time share company they
want my uh wife and her heirs to pay six
thousand dollars in back dues fees and
assessments for a timeshare that uh used
to belong to my deceased
uh father-in-law that nobody in this
family has used cares anything about her
once ever since he passed away
what do we do about that was there an
estate with assets
there is an estate with assets and the
assets are held in trust there was a
living will or a a living trust that was
done and my wife is the trustee uh along
with my but they sued you personally
they sued them personally yes all three
of the siblings of his siblings have all
three been sued personally did they
receive assets from something other than
the trust was their or their assets
outside the trust
no
nothing has come to them outside of the
trust not what's the size of the estate
uh the estate holds nothing in it any
longer but the home what was the truth
how much was in the trust originally uh
and the trust originally was a home and
a rental property the rental property
was sold for about 160 000
last year and used to pay off a second
mortgage it was on the main home
and
then there was ten dollars and that's
what was in the in the estate completely
okay here's why i'm asking all right
when you die what you own
stands good for what you owe
okay
and so let's just pretend there was no
trust involved and they had benefited
from this and had not paid off the time
share
and not paid the time share fees then
technically under contract law you'd
probably lose the lawsuit in this case
the estate
is all in a trust so it is all probably
protected from them
you're certainly not personally liable
unless you personally received assets
from the estate which you did not you
received assets from the trust
right
so i'm not an i'm not an attorney but
when you talk to one that's what they're
going to tell you so how does the fee
simple thing work how can time shares
just say you own this fee simple in
perpetuity no you're
you're you're well you you don't your
wife didn't but her father did
right okay and her father had a contract
with them and that contract has to be
paid off
during the estate being closed out
however this estate had no assets in it
except a trust all of which is protected
from other debtors so let's say that
there was a a credit card debt
right okay
normally if you sold the house off and
it was not in a trust you'd have to do
that but the trust is not liable for
that credit card debt right because it's
not the same entity as her as her father
so anyway technical details but you need
to talk to an attorney obviously which
company is this
uh i don't know what company it is it's
a timeshare here in florida up in uh
central florida yeah the lawsuit didn't
have a company name on it
it has an attorney that's representing
this particular timeshare yeah usually
it's not like an rci or something like
that it's an individual
uh timeshare unit
okay all right yeah yeah i would i would
get an attorney and i would beat the
snot out of these scum burgers
yeah
i thought that you'd enjoy it because
they're some of the most upstanding and
honest people in the world or timeshare
uh yeah they're just absolute crooks i
mean the the business is just a horrible
horrible business
and you should people you should just
stay away from but here's the thing your
wife here's what you need to separate in
your mind your wife is not personally
liable for the you know any of her
father's debts
including a debt to a timeshare company
what is liable is the estate
and the only question is uh whether or
not so if your wife took
and her sisters took 20 000 bucks or 30
000 bucks out of a cd that was in his
name and not in a trust sure and didn't
pay his bills
yeah the credit card company that he
didn't that you didn't pay could come
after them
i understand that's what that's the
premise they're using to come after you
what they what they're not apparently
informed of is the fact that the estate
didn't have any assets
yeah they're suing for foreclosure
yeah oh we would love for them to
foreclose
yeah well they're trying to foreclose on
my wife and her and my uh
they can't foreclose on them because
they don't own it
right that's what they're trying to do
trying to foreclose on them in this suit
yeah they don't own it you can't
foreclose on me if i don't own it you
could say you could sue me for
foreclosure on that time share i don't
own it
right and that's what that was what my
question to you is how can they sue them
i'm i'm afraid well i mean you can sue
anybody for anything you can just make
up crap and file lawsuits
it's happened to me i mean you can just
make up stuff and just lie you know
and basically that's what the timeshare
company's doing here they're just trying
to collect on something because they
smelled that this estate's got some
money in it and they didn't get paid
right and that's what that's what
they're coming after um and so
you know it just depends on how much
money you want to spend on principal on
this but uh you're probably going to
drop 10 grand
yeah to uh to go punch them in the nose
and that's what it's going to take and
if you need some help with this there's
an attorney that comes on here
periodically that hates the timeshare
business as much as i do
and he he beats him up all the time for
a living his name is scott montgomery in
springfield missouri
okay write that down and call scott and
tell him what's going on he can he can
probably make an example out of these
boys he's pretty tough and he knows his
stuff he's sharp he comes on the air
here with me uh to comment on the the
scum burgers and the timeshare business
all the time scott montgomery
springfield missouri there's timeshare
attorneys all over america that fight
the timeshare companies sure but uh he's
one that i just know of right off the
top of my head that you could get a hold
of him and you're gonna have to have
somebody defend you or counter sue
right
as your defense mechanism and
um
the other thing you could do is you
could file all kinds of complaints there
in florida
right with the state government the
different uh the commerce department and
other things for a faulty false lawsuit
and um yeah i would light them up
personally but it just depends on how
much hassle and what you want to go
through
uh you may be able to write them a check
for 5000 bucks and they go away
but um
but you know i don't know uh you that
probably is the more expedient thing to
do but you're dealing with scum
and it just gets your blood boiling and
makes you want to spend 25 000 to make
sure they get nothing
um
yeah i mean i've spent millions of
dollars on these things to make sure
that people get nothing
and i'll continue to do it just because
i'm that guy and i need a hobby you know
but um but some people don't want fool
with all that stuff and it is a pain in
the butt i'll tell you that so but you
do you do want to you have to stand up
sometimes and just say that's it i'm
done i'm not taking this anymore i'm not
going to like be lied about cheated
stolen from and not and not caught and
call it so
you you decide which which hill you want
to fight on because you're going to
fight on one someday
hey good question man we appreciate you
joining us open phones this hour this is
the ramsey show
and that's just one more instance of how
scummy the timeshare business is
don't go in the tiger cage
don't go in the tiger cage don't go in
there for the free dinner
the free
passes to wally world
the free
night stay at the resort
and then get pressured by some half butt
guy who couldn't get a job
cleaning out septic tanks which is
actually honorable business
and all of a sudden you
own yourself a time share oh and then
you die
with some money in your estate in trust
and your kids get sued
by your timeshare company
what a blessed group of people they are
unbelievable
stay away from this industry folks it's
nasty bad